- [Voiceover] We have other videos that go
into some depth on the Calvin cycle,
and we'll refer to that in this video
as the normal Calvin cycle,
and the focus of this
video is really a quirk
that diverts us from
the normal Calvin cycle,
and it's a quirk due to
this enzyme right here
whose shorthand name is rubisco.
So to get an appreciation for that quirk,
let's first do a very quick overview
of a normal Calvin cycle.
So we can start at any point,
but I'll start at the
point that is typically
started at,
and we can start with
this five carbon molecule.
And we're visualizing just the
carbons here for simplicity.
So each of these grey
circles represent a carbon.
There's other atoms a
part of this molecule,
but we're not drawing them,
and that's because the
carbon accounting is
what is interesting in--
Well, not only the Calvin cycle,
but also this variation, this diversion
that we're going to see,
that we're gonna call photo-respiration.
So, right over here, I've set it up so
that I have six molecules of this.
We call this ribulose
one, five, bisphosphate,
but because it's a mouthful,
the shorthand notation is R-U-B-P.
Sometimes people might say Roo-B-P,
or I guess you could
even say Rube-P somehow,
but each of these six Rube-P, or RuBPs,
can then react with a carbon dioxide.
So if I have six RuBPs,
well, they're gonna react
with six carbon dioxides,
and so one way to think about it is,
it's fixing the carbon
in that carbon dioxide.
It's taking this carbon that's part
of this gaseous carbon dioxide,
and fixing it as part
of an organic molecule.
Now, you might be tempted to say,
well, it's gonna create
six carbon molecules,
but then those will immediately become
12 three carbon molecules.
And notice, and it's
important to keep doing this.
Pause the video if you need to.
You can make sure that the
carbons are all accounted for.
Right over here, how
many carbons do we have?
Well, we have six times five,
so that's 30 carbons right over here,
and here we have six times one carbon,
so that's six carbons right over here.
So if we wanna account
for all of our carbons,
we should have 36 carbons right over here,
and we do.
We have 12 three carbon molecules.
This three carbon molecules,
when we go into some detail here
in the video on the Calvin cycle,
it's called three phosphoglycerate,
but that's not what the
focus is on this video.
The focus of this video is the enzyme
that actually does the fixing
of the carbon along with the RuBP.
And that enzyme, that character,
the character with the
quirks that we're going
to talk about, the shorthand, its name,
you could call it ribulose
one, five, bisphosphate
oxygenase-carboxylase,
but that's even more of
a mouthful than RuBP,
so people call it the nice
friendly name rubisco,
rubisco for short.
But you can learn a lot
about what rubisco does
from its name right over here,
and you can even learn a
little bit about its quirk
that we're about to talk about.
So it obviously involves
ribulose one, five bisphosphate,
and it does indeed involve that,
and then you see oxygenase,
dash, carboxylase.
Well, the carboxylase is what tells us
that it can deal with the
carbon dioxide right over here.
The carbon dioxide can
be one of the substrates
in a reaction with the ribulose
one, five, bisphosphate.
And so that's exactly what
it's doing in this reaction.
In a normal Calvin cycle,
it's acting as a carboxylase.
It is fixing that carbon.
It's making it part of,
if you view, you know,
if you view that carbon--
Actually, I won't do it that way
because here we have 12 as many.
But it's taking these carbon molecules,
and it's fixing them
into organic molecules,
some of which can eventually be used
to create glucose.
And that's what happens
in a typical Calvin cycle.
We use up some NadPhs.
We use up some ATPs,
and we go down.
Through this cycle, eventually,
we create some G3Ps, which are also
three carbon molecules.
G3P is short for
glyceraldehyde three phosphate,
for those of you who are interested,
and then, if we use this
accounting of those 12,
10 go back through the Calvin cycle
to regenerate our ribulose
one, five, bisphosphate,
and two of them exit the Calvin cycle,
and then can be used to produce
one six carbon glucose.
And so that's what happens
when everything is fine and dandy.
That's what the Calvin cycle's purpose is,
is to be able to have a store of energy
in the form of a glucose.
Now, you might have
already gotten a little bit
of the foreshadowing from rubisco's name.
Well, maybe it sometimes
acts as an oxygenase.
So instead of fixing carbon,
maybe sometimes it fixes oxygen,
and that is indeed the
quirk that I'm talking
about of rubisco.
So in photo-respiration,
instead of fixing carbon,
it fixes oxygen along with the ribulose
one, five, bisphosphate.
And you might say, "Why does it do that?"
And the answer is, well,
that's a really good question.
Some folks think, well,
that's just one of these
inefficiencies of a biological process.
It really shouldn't do it.
It's in some ways
detrimental to the plant.
It could be a side
effect, a legacy feature,
or side effect from ancient evolution
when there was very little
oxygen in the atmosphere,
and so this didn't seem like that bad
of an inefficiency.
But it does happen, and in particular,
the times where photo-respiration
is more likely to happen
with typical plants, often
referred to as C three plants,
and C three is referred to
because the first product
when you fix the carbon is
a three carbon molecule.
But this typically
happens, or this happens
with typical plants in
hotter than normal weather.
So let me write this down,
and I'll write it in a hot color.
Hot, hot conditions.
That's where it typically happens
with typical plants,
and why hot conditions?
Well, in hot conditions, first of all,
rubiso has more affinity.
Rubisco's affinity,
affinity to O2 increases.
So under normal conditions,
it tends to have more
affinity for carbon dioxide,
but under hot conditions,
these proteins are--
No protein is perfect.
It can morph a little bit,
so it has more affinity
to molecular oxygen,
and also, under hot conditions,
plants are worried about conserving water,
and so they will close their stomata,
stomata, stomata closed,
to preserve water, but when
the stomata are closed,
you have CO2 can't diffuse in,
can't diffuse in,
and O2 can't diffuse out,
can't diffuse out.
So your ratio of O2 to CO2 increases.
So O2 to CO2 ratio,
ratio increases.
So under hot weather,
the rubisco just wants to
work with the oxygen more.
It typically wants to work
with the carbon dioxide,
and also, because the stomata's closed,
and you don't have as easy diffusion,
well, this ratio is going to increase.
And so, things are just
more likely to react
with the oxygen,
especially the rubisco's
more likely to bump
into it in the right way
than it is with the carbon dioxide.
But let's think a little bit about why
this is inefficient.
Well, in this case,
it's fixing the oxygen,
and so it's not gaining those carbons
like we just saw in the typical
or the normal Calvin cycle,
and so here, and you can account--
I encourage you to keep pausing the video
and account for the carbons,
but here, you can no longer produce
your 12 three carbon molecules,
'cause you're not getting
these six carbons over here,
so instead, you can only produce six
of those three carbon molecules,
and then another six of
a two carbon molecule
called phosphoglycolate,
and once again, I'm not
showing all of the oxygens
and I'm not showing all the phosphates.
I'm just accounting for the carbons.
And so, this seems like a pretty bad loss.
You're not able to use those
carbons right over there.
Well, evolution has given us pathways
to at least start to salvage some of it.
But it's a pretty intense pathway
to get back some of those carbons,
and the reason why it wants to get back
some of those carbons is because,
remember, at the end of the day,
you want to attempt to
produce some glucose,
and you wanna have the
typical or the normal
Calvin cycle continue to happen,
but just so you get a sense
of what the salvage pathway
looks like,
this two carbon molecule right over here,
it has to be converted to glycolate,
then that has to go to the peroxisomes
where it becomes glycine
to the mitochondrion,
and you see this whole process here
just to be able to salvage it
into a few more of the
three carbon molecules,
and that's essentially what
happens right over here.
We get three more of the
three carbon molecules,
but we do lose, for the
way I've accounted of it,
three molecules of carbon dioxide,
and this one way that why it's called,
or one reasoning for why it's called
photo-respiration.
Respiration, we use oxygen,
and we produce carbon dioxide,
and that's exactly what's happening.
We're using oxygen, and we're
producing carbon dioxide.
And so, as you see, the mechanism,
it kind of makes the Calvin cycle--
It disrupts it, or
makes it less efficient.
And so, once again, why does this happen?
Well, it could just be a biological quirk
that has not been selected
strongly enough against,
or some people believe
it actually has some
not so well understood mechanism,
and it somehow helps
the plant in some way,
but it's a really interesting
thing that goes on,
and, you know, rubisco is not just some
very fringe molecule.
As you see, it's central
to the Calvin cycle,
and if you look at plant matter,
in particular plant leaves,
it'll represent roughly 20%
of the protein mass in those plant leaves.
So it's a very common
protein slash enzyme,
but it's got this quirk,
this quirk that takes
the plant down the path
of photo-respiration.